of course yeah we actually got a party
on Saturday this is Phi Sigma you for
gentlemen if Jonas tackles fraternity
hazing in his new film goat and while he
wasn't in a frat himself nick says he
can relate I like to think that living a
public life at times can be a bit like
it hazed a bit like very judged at times
not to mention Nick also has two older
brothers and we built a great group of
friends around us that we were all
willing to give each other a decent
amount of crap the different things so
you know we lived it out in wrong way
Joe has a tendency to time the time to
get a little bit of a hothead so you
gotta back your brother's up if things
go down so what did Nick's co-star and
producer James Franco think about the
pop stars performance anytime somebody
transitions from one medium into another
is gonna be you know some amount of
focus put on that and so the fact that
he was kind of doing that showed me like
okay he's gonna take this really
really threw himself into it any day